hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today I'm gonna show
you how to make some awesome knives for
Mother's Day
[Music]
welcome to another episode of outdoor
boys and today I'm making a Mother's Day
project a knife I'm gonna make a nice
kitchen knife for my mom Mother's Day is
around the corner so this will be
perfect now I have a bunch of these old
farriers rafts I got a like six of them
for like 10 bucks and they make really
good knife blanks the Steel's
high-quality it's already tempered and
heat treated so you don't need to use a
forge or anything you can just cut out
your knife shape polish it up and you're
off to the races
it's a great way to get into knife
making and one of the things I want you
guys to understand is this is very easy
okay there's lots of room for creativity
and skill but if you want to just start
and get into that making knives you
don't need a lot of equipment you don't
need a lot of space and you don't need a
lot of skill frankly everything you see
here is maybe 200 bucks worth of
equipment and tools and supplies and
everything on this table is all I am
going to use to build these knives kind
of give you an idea of how easy this
project is I'm gonna go ahead and hit
the timer on my phone here and I'm gonna
kind of tell you how much time has
passed as we do this so that you guys
can get a feel for what it takes to
build one of these knives
I've taking the angle grinder and
smoothed out three of these ferry
arrests and I'm about 32 minutes into
the project
okay we're about an hour and a half into
the project and you see we got the rough
profiles cut out but got a lot of
grinding to do to clean up the edges
alright one down two to go I got the
profile cut out nice the way I like it
we're two hours 15 minutes into this
project so grinding it took about 45
minutes for all three so we're moving
right along
[Music]
there we go that was a lot of work about
45 minutes of grinding just to get the
beginning of the edge on than life's now
I'm gonna finish it off with the belt
sander and that's gonna take a little
bit of time as well
[Applause]
we're three hours and 45 minutes into
this project and we now officially have
a knife got an edge on here it's not
razor sharp but this is a knife I mean
if we wanted to stop right here we could
this is a functional beautiful knife but
we're going to go ahead and put a handle
on it and then sharpen it up really nice
all right well we're at five hours ten
minutes and we've got the wood for the
handles ready to be drilled so we're
getting really close to being done all
we have left to do is to polish the
blades to mount the the wood on the
handles drill the holes you know set the
epoxy and then we're gonna sharpen the
Dickens out of these things so getting
really close to done but unfortunately
little Jacob here need some daddy time
and it's getting a little bit late so
we're gonna pick this up again tomorrow
now each one of these handles is unique
to the knife so I've taped them together
so I won't get them confused between now
and tomorrow and I think you need a
little diaper change it feel a little
bit soggy there buddy all right it's
another beautiful day and we're ready to
finish this project up so we are going
to go ahead and polish up the steel then
we're going to drill the holes for the
handle we're gonna put the handles on
well policy and all three knives on the
80-grit took me about 40 minutes I need
to do to 80 grit and then maybe 800 grit
or 600 grit and thousand grit and I'm
guessing it'll take me another 45
minutes to do all of that so let's get
cracking it's time-consuming
took about an hour 45 minutes to polish
all three blades a lot more time than I
expected so about six hours 45 minutes
total on this project so let's get
drilling on the handles and get those
handles on it's another beautiful day
I've got myself a new haircut and a
whole bunch of drill bits we're gonna
make this happen
let's do this the steel used in rasps is
extremely hard it's been specifically
heat treated to make it hard and this
can make it very difficult to drill
holes in it so what I do is I soften the
steel using a torch I heat up just the
handle and mess up the the heat
treatment temper it a little bit that
allows me to drill holes in it and I can
do that without messing up the edge so
all right once the Steel's turned that
blue get it nice and hot just let it air
cool and once it's cold we can drill it
[Music]
well it took about an hour and a half to
get the holes drilled in the metal and
then the holes drilled in the wood now
I'm ready to put the epoxy on it we let
it sit overnight and then we will be
very close to finished well I've got
three knives I'll clamped up ready to go
just let them sit overnight and then
we'll be ready to finish this project
I'm really excited best Mother's Day
present ever all right guys it's been 24
hours in the epoxy set so we're gonna
get these clamps off these knives and
get them grinded so the animals look
pretty good we just need to grind down
the pins take off the excess wood and
just get it all polished up we'll be
done
[Music]
so you may have noticed that these
handles keep changing colors they
started off purple that I sanded them
and they turned brown when you expose
purple heartwood to light it turns
purple darker and deeper purple and so I
just sanded this to make it all nice and
smooth so I got rid of most of the
purple but I'm gonna let these sit out
in the Sun for a day or two and they
should turn just a beautiful color of
purple we also need to sharpen these up
really put an edge on them there we go
guys about nine and a half hours not bad
there's a really fun project and
hopefully uh my mom is gonna enjoy this
I'm giving away one to my mom one to my
wife and one to a neighbor so I think
this is gonna make a nice nice present
on Mother's Day guys thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed this video make sure
to get out there and thank your wives
and thank your mothers for all they've
done for you it's a wonderful time of
year and a great time to remember the
women in our lives so don't forget
Mother's Day guys I promised you that I
would announce the winner of the belt
buckle giveaway today and the winner is
Papa Mike Simpson
so public Mike Simpson congratulations I
picked his comment from all the many
many awesome comments because it was
voted the most popular and also because
this is a big boy belt and Papa Mike
Simpson looks like he could fill it up
quite nicely so congratulations
I shoot me an email or shoot me a
message on Facebook Papa Mike Simpson
with your address and I will send you
your silver play button belt buckle well
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel don't forget to
[Music]
Melda thanks for watching we hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every week and don't forget to hit that
Bell button so you'll get notified when
we put out another great video